CRAIG FENTON: OK,
so our guest today
is the lead singer and
songwriter of an absolutely
iconic British rock band.
He's a brilliant lyricist.
And I encourage you to
listen to the songs.
Like, really listen
to the songs.
I think he's a
great storyteller,
and each song has
a message in it.
He's also a Welshman,
another one.
GETHIN JONES: Yes, he is.
CRAIG FENTON:
--and a family man.
In fact, his family
is here today with us.
And Stereophonics started
about 20 years ago in a garage.
Sound familiar?
Like Google?
And I think what
makes them stand out
is they're really
true to their roots.
They're real musicians that
have stood the test of time.
So just a few facts here.
Leapfrogged onto the
stage with the Brit Awards
for the Best New Group in 1998.
1998 ring a bell?
Huh?
Nine further awards since, six
platinum and multi-platinum
records.
Platinum record is
a record that sells
more than a million copies.
I think that's right, isn't it?
Quadruple platinum-selling
best of collection
called "Decade in the
Sun" sold 4 million plus.
11 top 10 singles, including
anthems like "Dakota,"
"Maybe Tomorrow."
One of four iconic British bands
to open the London Olympics
in Hyde Park in 2012.
Was anyone there?
I was.
It was an amazing concert.
A touring group, globally
selling out stadiums
still around the world.
I should probably say stadia.
And actually, Kelly's just
about to do a solo tour starting
in June.
I've just got my tickets.
They're playing at
the Hammersmith--
used to be called the
Hammersmith Apollo.
I think it's the
Eventim Apollo now.
So go online and
get your tickets.
Just do it after the talk.
Sold over 10 million albums
worldwide, 8 million in the UK
alone, making them one of
the most successful Welsh
and British rock
bands of all time.
And big on YouTube.
220,000 YouTube subscribers
and over 150 million
views on YouTube.
So Google and YouTube are very
proud to welcome Mr. Kelly
Jones.
[APPLAUSE]
KELLY JONES: Hello.
Hello.
GETHIN JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
KELLY JONES: Hello.
GETHIN JONES: Thank
you very much, Craig,
for those wonderful
introductions.
Kelly's was far
better than mine.
We'll talk about that later.
To be honest, the only
reason we said we'd do this
is because we've got a Google
tour just before coming here.
It's brilliant, isn't it?
KELLY JONES: Goodie bag.
GETHIN JONES: It's much better
than Hits Radio in Manchester.
I said that out loud.
Yeah, we've got a
goodie bag as well.
We don't know what's in it.
I think mine's a notebook.
I think you might have--
KELLY JONES: Well, he's trying
to convert me from Apple.
GETHIN JONES: [LAUGHS]
It's basically a bribe.
KELLY JONES: It is a bribe.
Yeah, I think [INAUDIBLE] the
other side, which we might do.
GETHIN JONES: I think the
first thing we should do
is just point out
that despite the fact
that we do have the same
surname, we're not brothers--
KELLY JONES: No.
GETHIN JONES: --I don't think.
KELLY JONES: Well, there's a
lot of us look the same where
we come from.
So you never know.
GETHIN JONES: Could be a cousin.
KELLY JONES: You never know.
GETHIN JONES:
Second cousin maybe?
KELLY JONES: I'll
be your cousin.
I'll be your brother.
You look more like me than
my brothers look like me.
I think I was the mistake there.
So there's a 10-year gap between
my brothers, [INAUDIBLE]..
GETHIN JONES: We talked about
that as well, your parents--
KELLY JONES: They actually
say we were all mistakes.
GETHIN JONES: Actually weird.
Jones is a weird thing in Wales.
This is a true story.
I actually hold a
world record for being
part of the largest gathering
of people with the same surname
under the same roof.
1,583 Joneses all got together
in the Millennium Center
in Wales in 2001.
And we beat the
Norbergs from Sweden,
who could only manage 596.
The show [INAUDIBLE] was
called "Jones, Jones, Jones."
They put a lot of
thought into it.
KELLY JONES: I didn't
get the invite.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, why
did you not get invited?
KELLY JONES: I don't know.
Was Tom Jones there?
GETHIN JONES: No,
because he's not a Jones.
KELLY JONES: No, but I am.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, exactly.
This is awkward.
Let's move on quickly, shall we?
Craig mentioned
there, actually, the--
actually, weirdly, with the
Stereophonics and the Google,
it's, like, 25-ish years
when it all started.
And it's quite a few
similarities between the two.
And as Craig
mentioned just before,
I suppose the biggest one
is that you both started
in a garage about 1992.
KELLY JONES: Yeah, to the
dismay of my neighbors.
Yeah.
Well, Stuart, the drummer,
lived in number 62.
And I lived in 54.
I was practicing "Highway
to Hell" by AC/DC in 54,
and he was practicing
in number 62.
So everybody in between was
getting a bit pissed off,
really.
So we just decided to maybe
come together in the same thing,
and we went up in
my old man's garage.
And then my brother Lee
came over from the pub,
and he was pretty annoyed as
well after about two hours.
And then we went to
the local youth club,
so when youth clubs existed.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
So were you, like, 17?
KELLY JONES: When I first
started running-- by then
I was 12, actually.
It was 1987.
GETHIN JONES: Oh, wow.
KELLY JONES: And then it
went on and on and on.
But when we became
the lineup that we
were on the first record,
that was about 1994.
So it was an overnight
success, Gethin.
It was a very long night.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, it
did take a little while.
But when it did, it
really kicked off,
as we'll mention in a bit.
But I suppose that
17, 18-year-old Kelly,
jamming in different garages
in number 62, number--
in your house-- 54.
What was he like?
What was a 17-year-old
Kelly Jones like?
KELLY JONES: I was all right.
I was pretty quiet, really.
I liked playing football.
I liked doing boxing.
I had two older brothers who
I was following them around,
you know.
But I was into the music
from a very young age
because my father was working--
going around to
working men's clubs.
So I would go round
carrying his speakers.
He was a singer, my dad.
He was professional
before I was born.
He was-- [INAUDIBLE].
And he did some shows of Roy
Orbison and people like that.
And when I was
growing up, his record
was on the jukebox in the
local pub, which was weird.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, bet it was.
KELLY JONES: So when I used to
go and watch him in the clubs,
he would give me a fiver
for carrying his speakers
and a Chinese takeaway
on the way home.
GETHIN JONES: Did you
have Chinese takeaway?
KELLY JONES: No.
GETHIN JONES: Oh, right.
You bought--
KELLY JONES: It was a
really good incentive
to go every weekend.
But I learned a lot from
watching him in the clubs.
Because if you could
play a working men's club
and succeed, then you're
doing something right,
you know, the way you pace the
set and all that kind of stuff.
So as much as I didn't
realize, I probably
learned a hell of
a lot doing that.
And then I end up doing
working men's clubs, and pubs,
and stuff like that
in the back of the van
and all that for many,
many years as well.
GETHIN JONES: By the way, he
changed his name, didn't he,
from Jones?
KELLY JONES: He was Jones.
And because at the time there
was Tom Jones and Jack Jones,
they changed his name
to Arwyn Davidson.
So in the phone
book, nobody could
find us, because obviously,
it was [INAUDIBLE]..
But yeah, I don't know where
the Davidson came from.
GETHIN JONES: It's not
exactly Tom Jones, is it?
KELLY JONES: No.
GETHIN JONES: Arwyn Davidson.
KELLY JONES: No, and he was
Tom Woodward, wasn't he?
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: That's
why he changed.
You mentioned
boxing and football.
But you also had quite a keen
interest in writing as well,
didn't you?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: That's the thing
about all your tracks for me.
I don't know.
It's a bit of a wordsmith
in there-- script--
you love films?
KELLY JONES: Well, I was
pushed in the band, really.
I mean, I like
playing the guitar.
But because my old man was a
singer, every band I joined,
they would kind of
push me to the front
because they just assumed
because my father could sing,
I would be the
singer sort of thing.
Not until about 18 or 19, I
felt that comfortable with that.
The first six or seven years,
I wasn't that keen on it,
but I would do it.
And then when I
got to about 18, I
was working in a fruit
and veg stall about 16,
and I was in art school.
So I left school at
16, went to art school.
Did that for five years,
filmmaking and animation.
And during that time
of being in art school
and working in a
market, I would see
lots of people in
the market and get
to know all different
walks of life.
And I would be writing a
lot of the the words down
on the back of brown bags.
While I was serving
carrots, I would
be writing stuff like "A
Thousand Trees" and "Local Boy
in the Photograph."
All that was literally written
in a market stall, really.
But then I would
go to film school.
And because I was
doing sequential art
and storyboarding, I would be
doing filmmaking sequences,
and I'd be writing dialogue.
So the dialogue
then became lyrics.
Because I'd go to rehearsals
on a Thursday and a Sunday,
and some of the dialogue I wrote
for films I was trying to make
would end up coming
in songs, like "She
Takes Her Clothes
Off," and [INAUDIBLE],,
and all that kind of stuff.
So a lot of it was
very filmic, you know,
because they were kind of
crossing over in my life
at that point in time.
So it was all very
visual and very--
very filmmaking themes, really.
But the music was
very authentic.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah it's like
a autobiographical, wasn't it,
in all the things--
your experiences,
which made up the first album.
And literally, word did get out
then about the Stereophonics.
KELLY JONES: It did, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: And it's a
bit of a weird question,
but did you want to be famous?
Were you thinking about it?
KELLY JONES: No, Stuart the
drummer wanted to be famous.
And he became famous
for many, many reasons.
And he was lovely,
and he was crazy,
and he's all of
the above, really.
But he always joked that
he wanted to be famous.
He wanted a BMW.
He wanted a swimming pool.
And he got it all.
And I never really
wanted to be famous.
I just knew that I had
something I was trying to say.
And I still haven't really
worked out what that is.
But it's a drive that is still
within me which I can't really
turn off.
I know the energy that
gives me that drive
is the same energy
that can drive
me a bit crazy on down time.
So I kind of always have to have
some sort of project going on
to kind of focus that
in the right way,
if you know what I mean.
But the fame thing and
the celebrity thing,
it was never really
on my agenda, really,
and still isn't, really.
GETHIN JONES: The thing
is with the success,
it comes, doesn't it,
whether you like it or not.
When was it that you
suddenly thought,
actually, hang on a minute here.
We're going to be quite big.
This is happening.
KELLY JONES: Yeah, well,
people started putting us
on the front of the magazines,
and we were selling out
arenas and stadiums by
our second album, which
was like 10 albums ago.
So it wasn't fast, but
it appeared to be fast.
Because obviously, we'd
been working since I was 12.
So for a long time, I would say
for the first 12, 13, maybe 14
years, I never really
felt comfortable
on stage doing our gigs
because I wasn't convinced
that the people there
really liked us.
And I wasn't--
GETHIN JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
KELLY JONES: I think a lot of
musicians feel it, possibly.
And it took me a while to
work out the common sense,
well they must be there.
They must like us because
they bought a ticket, right?
GETHIN JONES: I'm
thinking that now.
But [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the worry.
They could leave at
any time, you know?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
So it takes you a while
to get comfortable
in your own skin doing
something that's quite
a vulnerable thing, I guess.
But once I kind of got used
to that, I was into it.
But I didn't really
love the fact--
not in a grumpy way-- just I
never felt comfortable walking
on red carpets and stuff, like
that wasn't really my scene.
My wife loves it, but
I'm not very good at it.
GETHIN JONES:
[INAUDIBLE] in '98,
we mentioned, you were then sort
of selling out gigs everywhere.
And probably for any kind
of Welsh musician, then
you hit the big time.
You duet with Tom
Jones, in Cardiff,
you know you've made it.
KELLY JONES: We did.
Yeah, I bent his ear
one night in a bar.
GETHIN JONES: Did you?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Was that
your idea, was it?
KELLY JONES: Well, he
was making a duets album,
and I'd seen all these
other people doing it.
And that was a bit
like, oh, hello.
So I told him I love Sam
Cook, and Otis Redding,
and all this stuff.
And I think I convinced
him over a few pints
in some pub in Cardiff.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: And then
we did the track.
And I think that was Tom's,
one of Tom's most successful
albums.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
Good guy?
KELLY JONES: He was amazing.
I mean, I stood opposite him
and there's a glass screen.
We sang it twice
looking at each other.
And then he said let's go for
a Chinese, and that was it.
And I said, all right.
So we went to Baker Street.
And we had a lovely meal.
And that was that.
And so we stayed mates.
And then he took
me under his wing,
and took me around
for weeks and weeks
to lots of really
nice restaurants
that opened the door for him.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: So,
yeah, he's amazing.
He's a machine.
GETHIN JONES: Still a mate?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Still a friend?
KELLY JONES: Yeah, he is, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: I feel
like Chinese food
is going to be a theme here.
KELLY JONES: I didn't
mean it to be a theme.
Yeah, it was a big
part of my youth.
GETHIN JONES: It's
amazing how things
changed as well,
because obviously, I
was a fan growing up.
But it was like a
lot of the songs
were anthems to me and my
friends growing up as well.
And I remember sort of
you doing gig support
in bands, like Feed, and
like Ocean Color Scene.
And then all of a sudden,
they're supporting you in gigs.
That must have been a
very strange transition
for a very humble lad from
Cwmamman, in the valley.
KELLY JONES: Yeah, it was.
It was weired, because we
were doing cover versions
by Aerosmith, and the Black
Crows, and Lenny Kravitz,
and all that one month.
And the next six
months later, we're
playing Wembley Stadium
with them all and above them
on the bill.
It's a very bizarre
thing because you're not
ready for that, obviously.
Your brain can't
quite compute that.
But we were very lucky.
We had a lot of major band
[INAUDIBLE] on the road.
We did David Bowie's last tour
across America, The Reality
Tour.
We did the U2 Elevation
Tour, just after 9/11,
in Madison Square Garden.
And all the firemen
came on the stage.
We've been really-- The
Who took us on tour.
That was the first major
[INAUDIBLE] we did with them.
GETHIN JONES: And
you're a fan anyway?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
Yeah, it was amazing.
We had a [INAUDIBLE] football
match with David Bowie.
It was pretty bizarre.
GETHIN JONES: Oh, really?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
The thin White Duke was on the
side of the pitch heckling me.
There's some things you
just don't forget, you know.
GETHIN JONES: Was
he like at midfield.
KELLY JONES: He was amazing.
Because it was the Reality Tour.
He was actually playing himself.
He didn't have an alter
ego or anything us.
We bummed around, and he'd
come in the dressing rooms.
And he'd watch us soundcheck.
Because we were trying to
be very quick soundchecking.
You try of this
guitar for 40 seconds,
try a bit of that
one for 40 seconds.
Do a bit of that.
He'd be watching, and
then he'd come over to me,
and put his arm around me.
He goes, you know, if you
extended a few of those songs,
you might be onto something.
So he was-- he was really
lovely to us, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, he knew
a thing or two, as well,
didn't he?
KELLY JONES: He did
know a thing or two.
He was a Jones.
GETHIN JONES: Was he?
KELLY JONES: Yeah, his
real name's Jones too.
GETHIN JONES: I
didn't know that.
I think we all are,
originally, aren't we?
Change it as we go along.
KELLY JONES: Sorry to
bring that back around.
GETHIN JONES: It is
fascinating to me,
because I know you say you're
uncomfortable about the fame,
but it actually sounds
like you're very
relaxed in that environment.
Because it-- because
you know what it is.
KELLY JONES: I'm
relaxed with musicians.
I'm relaxed with people
who do the same thing as me
once I get to know them.
But I'm not very comfortable
sitting on a table
in like an award ceremony
and all that kind of stuff.
Probably because we
never really win.
No--
GETHIN JONES:
Nominated a few times.
KELLY JONES: Nominated--
yeah, I'm joking.
GETHIN JONES: Have
you been starstruck?
Has there been an
awkward moment where
you felt like a very normal
person with this big--
KELLY JONES: I've been
starstruck by all of them.
At first, I'm very silent.
And I don't really
like meeting somebody
lest they meet us back.
But we've got some-- we
did the Stones tours.
And everybody took us,
around about that time, 2000,
and you walk into Keith
Richards' dressing room.
And he's got a 12 foot snooker
table and a Shepherd's Pie.
And you're not allowed
to bust the crust.
He has to be the one that
takes the first portion.
GETHIN JONES: Really?
KELLY JONES: And, of course,
I bring Stuart in there.
Then I go there's a
12th foot snooker table.
He goes, oh, I love
a bit of snooker.
And then he went straight
into the Shepherd's pie.
GETHIN JONES: No.
KELLY JONES: So
they send it back
and had to get another
one before Keith saw it.
GETHIN JONES: I didn't
realize that was
a ritual, that was a thing.
KELLY JONES: It's
the truth, yeah.
And then he sat me down, and
he had a chat with us, and he--
and he was with his two
daughters, who are now models,
I think, but they
were quite young then.
And he drew a map of Wales--
Britain, and he put a
red line around Wales.
And he said that's
where the dragons live.
Because I think his
mother was Welsh.
GETHIN JONES: Probably
a Jones at some point.
KELLY JONES: She
was Jones as well.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
And by the way, if you see a
dragon in the Blueberry room,
later on, if you're
having a meeting,
that will be Kelly's
daughters, who've done that.
KELLY JONES: Oh, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Just been--
KELLY JONES: They draw
dragons wherever they go.
It's a Welsh thing.
GETHIN JONES: It's graffiti.
It's actually very good.
KELLY JONES: It
wasn't bad, was it.
GETHIN JONES: A real talent.
So now you're at super stardom.
You are running the show.
Just quick, did
you have a rider?
KELLY JONES: A rider?
GETHIN JONES: Yeah,
do you have a rider?
KELLY JONES: No, we don't
have a Shepherd's Pie, no.
GETHIN JONES: No, but
what was your rider?
KELLY JONES: Same as
we go, now, just--
GETHIN JONES: Chinese.
KELLY JONES: No Chinese, no.
The usual, really-- white wine,
red wine, beer, spirits, water.
GETHIN JONES: That's old school.
KELLY JONES: It's
never really changed.
GETHIN JONES: Bit of whisky?
Because they say you
have the whiskey voice.
KELLY JONES: I've
never liked whisky.
See, I've read that.
GETHIN JONES: Oh, really?
KELLY JONES: No,
whisky gravel voice.
I gargle sandpaper and stuff,
but no, I never drank whisky.
No.
GETHIN JONES: Good
question, yeah?
KELLY JONES: I like
vodka, but this is water.
GETHIN JONES: That's
what you think.
Kelly, how would you--
I was chatting
with Craig before,
and, I mean, what's happened
with Google is incredible.
They stay at the
top of their game.
They're market leaders.
How do you do that?
How do you stay at the top?
And you've been
doing it for so long.
KELLY JONES: I
think for me I like
to learn stuff all the time.
So I think when we
got signed, I always
thought that was the
first step on the ladder.
And then I thought-- it
was just after the Brit pop
kind of explosion, really.
So it was Oasis and [INAUDIBLE].
But a lot of the bands
that were around,
they all kind of fell apart.
And by watching that, you could
see, if you haven't really
got the craft, or the
songwriting together,
then when the scene goes away,
you kind of go away with it.
And I didn't want to
be part of a scene.
I didn't want to be
part of the Welsh scene,
when they started
making nothing.
Because I didn't want to
be attached to anything.
To me, it was about
always wanting
to leave behind a
catalog of music that
stood the test of time.
That's all I ever
want to achieve.
And so that's all I've
ever wanted to do.
That's all I've ever focused
on, is this the catalog.
And every time I
make a new record,
I try to play guitar
in a different way,
sing in a different way,
learn to play the piano,
bring different musicians in.
Whatever it might
be, each time you
do it, if you're not
challenging the sound of what
you're trying to make--
and I guess looking
up to people,
whether it's Prince,
or Bowie, or Madonna,
or whoever it was at that time.
You're always trying
to make something
that you can't quite do yet.
And then you got to learn
how to do it, you know.
And I think by doing
that, you kind of stumble
across accidents.
Sometimes it works, sometimes
it really doesn't work.
But then sometimes
when you hit, you know,
like we brought our "C'est
La Vie" a few years ago,
people thought,
who were 14 and 15,
thought that was our first song.
And there was lots
of 15-year-old kids
in the front row.
And because the energy of
that song talked to them.
And then they look
at, and then they go,
there's actually another nine
albums I better go and look at.
So it's constantly
trying to do our thing.
There's people who've
followed us since '96,
and there's some people who
only discovered us last year.
And that's kind of--
that revolving door is the
most important part for us.
Because if you're only going
to cater to the people who just
want you to keep making
"Word Gets Around," then
you're not going to
really get very far.
You're going to have a bunch
of people in the show as old
as me, and I don't really want
to play to them all the time.
I want to play to everybody.
It's about trying to keep
it growing and developing.
And the internet has
really helped in some ways,
because we wouldn't
have played in places
like Mexico City, and
Kuala Lumpur, and all
these different places,
all over the world,
because these kids
are just finding
our music through streaming
and stuff like that.
So Mexico City, people
crying in the front row.
Like 15-year-old
kids who never--
it's quite bizarre.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: It's really weird.
Actually, I did this
earlier, because I thought
I'd make the use
of being in Google,
and I had a look to
see where you were
most searched around the world.
Do you have any
ideas where that is?
I mean, that's a tough
question, isn't it?
KELLY JONES: Cardiff.
GETHIN JONES: Well,
let's have a look--
KELLY JONES:
Probably not Cardiff.
GETHIN JONES: Let's
go around the world.
Let me get it up
on the screen now.
This is where it's at-- as you
expect, the United Kingdom.
I mean, when was your
last gig in St. Helena?
KELLY JONES: I'm not quite
sure even where that is.
Where is that?
GETHIN JONES: You got the
UAE there and then Australia
as well, that comes up.
KELLY JONES: We've just
come back from there.
Yeah, we did the [INAUDIBLE].
GETHIN JONES: They
like you there.
And then cities wise,
as you can imagine,
we'll never let you down.
We'll always be for
you there, Kelly.
There we are, unbelievable,
pair up in threes, in Cardiff.
KELLY JONES: That's pathetic.
32 in Liverpool.
Wonder what that's all about.
GETHIN JONES: I'm hoping
that's million, though, Kel.
They just didn't
have the room for it.
So that's good.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
Melbourne.
GETHIN JONES: And
on a serious note,
though, and I might be a
little bit biased saying this,
but you talk about constantly
trying to renew things,
like "1,000 Trees,"
'97, "Dakota,"
2005, one of my favorite tracks
of all time, "Indian Summer,
2013.
That's 15 odd years.
It still sounds brilliant to me.
Has there been a record where
you thought this is brilliant,
this is definitely
going to do well,
that hasn't, or vise versa?
Does that happen?
Or do you even think--
KELLY JONES: The only song
I've ever written which lasted,
which was written
in about 10 minutes,
and took about three hours
to record, was "Dakota."
And the minute that I wrote
that in a hotel room, that's
the only time I've ever text
a record company guy and gone,
I think I've got--
GETHIN JONES: Really?
KELLY JONES: Yeah,
that's the only one.
Apart from that, I don't
really pick the singles.
I mean, I write
them, record them.
And then everybody
gets together.
And they say they like
this, they like that.
And I've never tried to write
a single, like a factory
kind of writer, you know.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: So,
no, it's quite funny
how they come about really.
GETHIN JONES: And there
are challenges as well,
in any business, as
there is in a band.
Like you're four now, but
you've been a different four
a couple of times over the
years, if that makes sense.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: That must be
really, really difficult.
But is there a drive
in you that thought
I've got to make
these changes if we're
going to sustain our success?
KELLY JONES: Well, I
think, like going back,
the drive is the force of
what keeps every band going.
If it's really what you are.
I don't think I kind
of choose really.
I don't sit down and
try to write songs.
I think the songs kind
of channel through you.
They kind of come out that way.
But I've got that drive
where I go to the studio,
and I'll stay there till
2:00 in the morning.
I'll get up and I'll do the
family stuff in the morning.
And then I'll go back
there by 10 o'clock,
before the engineers turn up.
It's just, when I'm in
that mode, I love it.
That's when I feel the
most free and I feel most
in the flow of what I'm doing.
And it's solving problems,
and it's challenging,
and all that sort of stuff.
And it's frustrating.
And it's everything
above all that.
But the rewards, when you
actually make those songs,
they're only yours for a
certain amount of time.
And for that little
block of time,
you can kind of see them and
manipulate them a little bit.
And then once you kind
of hand them over,
then fortunately
and unfortunately,
they kind of become
marketing tools for people
to sell records.
And then they become the songs
again when you play live,
you know.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: So it kind
of goes a bit strange.
And then you look
back at over 20 years,
and there's a lot of them.
And thankfully, we've
been a band that
has got a lot of big
songs on every album,
so it's not just dependent
on a one hit here
or a one hit there.
GETHIN JONES: You touched on
a few things in the answer
before actually.
And one of them
was the internet,
and now you're huge in
Mexico, and St. Helena, which
you learned today.
KELLY JONES: And a couple
of people in Melbourne, too.
GETHIN JONES: Social media is
such a big part of everything
now, isn't it?
Especially in terms of promoting
your brand and the music.
Stereophonics have
accounts, but not Kelly.
KELLY JONES: No.
GETHIN JONES: Why not?
KELLY JONES: I've never
felt the need, really.
I guess some people
need validation
and they like
telling people what
they do in their everyday life.
I suppose my outlet
is in my music.
I've never really wanted to have
a Twitter account or Instagram
account, or anything like that.
I prefer-- maybe it's
an old fashioned thing,
but I prefer, if I am
an artist, if that's
what people want to
call what I do is,
then I prefer the art to kind of
speak for what it is that I do.
If people know too much about my
personal life or my real life,
then the words that
I'm writing, they're
going to be very hard for people
to interpret in their own way.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: So
it's always wanting
to be open for interpretation.
GETHIN JONES: Does it
dilute it, as well?
KELLY JONES: I think
it dilutes it a bit.
And I think--
I think there's an element of
mystery when I was growing up
that I didn't know about any
of the artists that I love.
And I couldn't find out
anything about those artists.
I was an AC/DC fan.
I was an Otis Redding fan.
I couldn't find anything.
Now you can find
an AC/DC t-shirt
in [INAUDIBLE]
which is annoying.
Because I couldn't
find one anywhere.
I wrote a letter
to the fan club.
It took three years for a reply.
GETHIN JONES: You should
have sent the pitch in.
You should have
just sent an email.
KELLY JONES: So I come from a
different time in that sense.
And I quite like--
I suppose it's an
old school thing.
An artist is meant to be seen
and not touched and all that,
but I don't really take
it to that serious extent.
But I've never
really felt the need,
and I haven't
seriously got the time
to be telling people
my every move, really.
Everybody in the office will
say, can you send us a picture
when you're making a record.
And I'll send one.
Where it goes, I
don't really know.
And I don't really want
to be reading comments
about what I do
either, because I think
that can distract as well.
Because not everybody's
going to like what I do.
And not everybody is
going to care what I do.
But if I start reading
what everybody's doing,
then it's only going to get
in the way of what I do next.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: I mean, I
do it for me, really.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: Ultimately,
every song I've ever written,
I've had to write because I was
going through whatever I was
going through to get it out.
And then, you can have it.
But the main reason I've done
it is because I need to do it.
And so it's not really for
anybody else at that point.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: You know?
GETHIN JONES: It's
interesting, and actually
trying to just googling
Kelly, you can't really
find out that much about you.
And I think there's a small
paragraph about family
and personal life.
It's quite funny, I pride
myself on diligence and research
doing my work, but
coming to Google,
to do a gig for
Google is a bit weird.
Because you're going
to Google, and then you
go what do I do now?
Like, you know, googling Google.
But, yeah, there's not
much about you in there,
about your family life.
And just watching you
now, with the girls,
it's obvious that you're a dad,
first, and they're great girls.
And you're mates
with them as well.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: How have you--
how have you balanced that?
I mean, you're touring, you've
writing albums, you're gigging.
How do you balance that life?
KELLY JONES: Well, we've got--
I've never really been a dad
they wanted nannies, and help,
and stuff like that.
Everything we have
around us is all family.
And it's important.
Now the girls are
older, I'll only
go away for two, three weeks
at a max, and then come back,
and then I'll go away
again and come back.
So it's not-- before
we would go away, do
an American tour for six
weeks, go straight to Australia
for another eight weeks.
And you'd be gone
forever, really.
But it's an important
balance to keep.
The hours I put in of
being a father, and doing--
getting up and doing
the school runs,
and doing all the stuff,
the relationships you build
are hopefully, and
it seems to be,
paying dividends for
the relationships you
have in the years where they
can want to communicate more
with you.
And I've always thought
that was important.
I had a good relationship
with my parents, my brothers,
and all the rest of us.
So I don't really want to
put anything before that.
So that is always,
if I get a schedule,
it's come to the point,
the half terms are in pink.
And I have to kind of work
tours around some of that stuff.
Because you want to be around.
And then luckily,
they came today.
They got a free goody bag.
They'll probably be
all right now today.
GETHIN JONES: I was
going to say, actually,
do they think you're cool?
KELLY JONES: No.
GETHIN JONES: Or is today
probably the best thing
you've ever done with them.
KELLY JONES: They
thought I was cool
up until about four years ago.
And since they started
secondary school,
it's kind of like
on the low down.
GETHIN JONES: Is it?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
They don't-- we don't--
even the school,
the school asked
me to go in to do a
battle of the bands,
and all the stuff like
that, judging and--
I said no, because
I want the kids
to walk in their own footsteps.
I don't want them to
walk in what I've done.
I want them to be
their own people
and all that sort of stuff.
So they don't talk
about me in school.
If somebody googles me and finds
out about it-- googles me--
GETHIN JONES: Well done, Kelly.
KELLY JONES: I wasn't--
GETHIN JONES: You
didn't mean to do it.
KELLY JONES: No.
No, they try to keep it
private and so do we.
GETHIN JONES: It
was weird, they're
probably finding out
what you're doing
on a day to day basis
from social media
more than they are you
telling them, basically.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
Yeah, I don't really
know what I'm doing.
GETHIN JONES: I didn't know
you're doing a gig in Mexico
next week, dad.
KELLY JONES: Well,
the thing that
winds me the most about all
this stuff, and me and my wife
have many
conversations about it.
I have people coming
up to me telling me
what my family are
doing and I don't know.
GETHIN JONES: It's
creepy, isn't it?
KELLY JONES: Like, yeah,
like the hair dresser
will say to me, I saw
Jakki doing so on--
I'm like, oh, when?
I hadn't even found
out about it yet.
But they know about it.
GETHIN JONES: Who
is your hairdresser?
Because you have got great hair.
[INAUDIBLE] I've always
thought that about you.
KELLY JONES: It's
not down to him.
GETHIN JONES: Oh.
KELLY JONES: He just cuts hair.
GETHIN JONES: Welsh,
it's Welsh hair.
KELLY JONES: No, Johnny.
I'm not giving him
a plug, no chance.
GETHIN JONES: Listen,
I've babbled on enough.
If you've got a question for
Kelly, please, please, please
feel free to ask away.
That's why we're here.
And weirdly, they have
put like this sort
of a comedy mic in the middle.
That's the most sort
of unattractive way
of like-- who's going to go
up there to start a question.
KELLY JONES: I wouldn't.
GETHIN JONES: That's
a lot of pressure.
I wouldn't do that.
Anyway, so we have got
a roving mic as well.
So you can put your hand
up and they'll come to you.
So have a think if you
got anything to ask Kelly.
But before we do that, one
last thing I'd like to touch on
is the fact you're also
going to be doing solo tour.
KELLY JONES: I am, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Which might
surprise a lot of people.
And I know you like
to do them every now
and then, like every decade.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Was it 2007
you did your last one?
KELLY JONES: Yeah, the
band is a bit like having
a good marriage, really.
They try to give me some space.
And I'll say, look,
it's not you, it's me.
I need to go off and do
my own thing for a bit.
And it's just-- you come to the
end of the world tour and part.
You think that you
want to quit for a bit,
because you're a
bit bored, or you're
a bit fed up with hotel rooms,
and buses, and stuff like that.
But in reality, I think, is
you want to try something new.
So doing a solo tour,
you get a chance
to talk about how the
songs are written,
why you've written those
songs, do versions of the songs
that people have
never heard before.
Do new songs that you've never
played, and may make a record,
may not make a record.
And it's a chance to
be a bit more, I guess,
personal with the people
that come to watch you.
Because when you play in a
big show, in the stadium,
with the big lights, and the
screens, and all the rest
of it, then it becomes
very much based
on anthems, and big
songs, because that's
what people are there for.
They're for a good night out.
But when you do the
solo show, we've
got a guy playing
the trumpet, we've
got a girl playing the
violin, and there'll
be some very raucous
moments, but then very
kind of beautiful moments.
It's a very different
kind of dynamic to it
than a Stereophonics show.
As a musician, it's nice to
try to do that sort of stuff,
because then you
learn things from that
and then you can take
on to do other things.
GETHIN JONES: And the
boys are fine with that?
They fully support that?
KELLY JONES: They
don't know yet.
No, they do know, yeah.
Well, Richard-- I've been
in school with Richard
since he was three.
GETHIN JONES: Richard
Jones, that is.
KELLY JONES: He's Jones.
And they thought
we were brothers.
And he had his name
tattooed on his neck.
Actually, speaking
of Jones, when
Richard turned up
to school one day,
after going for a
tattoo, when he was 15--
he shouldn't have
been obviously--
and he had Jonsey
written on his arm.
But it was spelt wrong.
GETHIN JONES: Oh, no.
KELLY JONES: So I was
the person that told him
that it actually says Jonsey.
They put the E in the
wrong way, wrong place.
And then I think he had to go
back and have it tattooed over
with a larger skull.
GETHIN JONES: Right.
So what is it now, like
John E Skull White?
KELLY JONES: It was Johns--
e-y, instead of writing
it Jones with a Y. Yeah,
he was wrong anyway.
GETHIN JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
maybe, just a space--
KELLY JONES: He's got a big arm.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: Yeah,
he has got a big arm.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: But this was art
by Roy in the Rhonda Valley.
GETHIN JONES: Oh.
KELLY JONES: I hope
he's not still there.
If he is--
GETHIN JONES: You're
giving him a plug, but not
your hairdresser.
KELLY JONES: If he is, there's
always spellcheck on Google.
And so, yeah, so
what was we saying?
Oh, yeah, he did give me
permission, yeah, he did, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Solo tour, which
starts in Scotland, actually,
doesn't it?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Start of June.
And I like the fact
Kelly's giving himself
a day of for his birthday.
KELLY JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
GETHIN JONES: And do you
mind if I say, you're 45.
KELLY JONES: 45, yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah, I
mean, like, you just--
I suppose you've answered
this question already,
but you're not given--
you're not-- you don't
want to stop, do you?
This is a constant
journey for you.
KELLY JONES: I don't.
When I stop, I go
a bit mad, really.
So--
GETHIN JONES: You play football.
Could've been a boxer.
Quite handy.
KELLY JONES: I
stop after a pint.
No, I like doing what I do.
I like doing--
there was a part I
started doing some directing
in the videos and screenplay
writing.
I did that for a bit with BAFTA.
And I loved doing that.
But end of the day, it all comes
back to storytelling, really.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: And I do it
best, I think, through music.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah,
it's definitely
been your thing, for sure.
Do you mind if we take a few
questions from the floor?
KELLY JONES: No, I don't mind.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, it's a
pleasure to meet you.
And firstly, thank
you for the music.
KELLY JONES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Been a big fan.
I've got one question
around the storytelling
that you've mentioned already.
Two songs are a particular
favorite of mine, bit
abstract ones perhaps.
"Rainbows and Pots
of Gold," which
is a song about,
presumably about a breakup.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And "Vegas
Two Times," which
is quite a rocky song, which is
two very, very different songs.
It's a bit of a kind of
strange question to ask,
because I just want to
know a bit more about what
those songs were about.
And a bit selfish
question, I suppose.
KELLY JONES: Well, "Rainbows
and Pots of Gold" was about--
quite dark, actually.
GETHIN JONES: Just
lowered the tone.
He's definitely
KELLY JONES: It's
not lowered the tone.
GETHIN JONES: Could we not find
a more positive first question?
KELLY JONES: It was--
let's say I was with
a childhood sweetheart
for many, many years.
You're not going
to like the answer.
GETHIN JONES: It was
an expensive fine,
that's for sure.
KELLY JONES: We broke up.
And then I discovered that she
was then with my best friend.
So the song was about me
then offering an olive branch
to him, so we could kind of
still be friends sort of thing,
because we had a
major, major fight.
And the police came
and took us away.
That's the very, very
diluted version of it.
But that's kind of--
I'm sure my kids
are going to quiz me
on that one in the
car on the way home.
"Vegas Two Times"
was I went to Vegas--
GETHIN JONES: Twice.
KELLY JONES: Well,
that's the thing.
I went to make a video
with Tom Jones in LA,
but we went via
Vegas, because he
was playing his last night
of a 15-night stand in Vegas.
So when we went to see Tom--
this was in 1998 maybe--
so we stayed up all night
with Tom Jones having a drink.
And then we watched his
show the next night.
And because we'd kept me him all
night, when he came on stage,
he had about 15
glasses of water.
And he put a spotlight
on us in the booth.
And he said if you're wondering
why all these waters are here,
he said because those
bastards kept me up all night.
And then we had to leave Vegas
the next day to go back to LA
to make the video.
But we got lost.
And as we were leaving, we went
round in some weird circle.
And we ended up back in Vegas.
And we literally had
to leave two times.
And that's what it was.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So thank
you for coming.
It's really cool to meet you.
I was wondering, given
kind of your job,
it's obviously a very
high-pressure job,
and there's a lot of--
the energy must be
really crazy, probably
really takes a lot out of you.
So I'm wondering how do you
actually balance your life?
You talked a little bit about
it between your family life
and personal, but what
do you do personally
to kind of take the edge off
when things get-- when they
escalate, when you're
on tour, for whatever,
eight weeks,
non-stop, et cetera.
KELLY JONES: Not enough really.
I'm pretty crap at giving
myself any time, I have to say.
I kind of get into a bit of
a treadmill, of when I start,
I'll do the work, and
I'll do the shows,
and I kind of get
engrossed in it.
And when I'm with
the family, I'm
very much engrossed in that.
And the only thing I kind of do
outside of that really is I'll
go for a run or something
like that, or watch films,
or stuff like that.
But a lot of the time,
I've never really
been very good at giving
myself back as much as I need.
So I guess I find
most of the release--
I feel more calm
when I'm writing,
or I'm recording or playing.
But the time-- unfortunately,
when you're on the road,
you have two and a half hours on
stage, and the rest of the time
is in hotel rooms, which
I can't stand really.
That's the bit that, you know--
jet lagged in the
middle of a hotel
in Australia, on the other
side of the world, when
you family's on the other
side, and you're all
on the wrong clock.
I don't enjoy that part.
So, I don't know, I'm still
learning on that side of it.
Not quite been worked out.
GETHIN JONES: So random fact
is that you actually support
Leeds United, don't you?
KELLY JONES: I do.
I think they're going
to mess it up as well.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
The won last night, [INAUDIBLE]
But when's the last time
you saw Leeds
United play, Kelly?
KELLY JONES: When
they were playing
Real Madrid in the quarterfinal,
the European Cup, which
was about--
GETHIN JONES: Two years back.
KELLY JONES: 15 years ago.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
See, you need to
watch Leeds more.
That will help.
That's my [INAUDIBLE]
KELLY JONES: Yeah,
you're right actually.
I'm crap.
People ask me to go to
football, or golf, or do--
I'll say, yeah, and
then I never do.
I like a pint of Guinness,
I do like to have
a pint of Guinness.
GETHIN JONES: There you go.
KELLY JONES: Sorry,
I forgot about that.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
KELLY JONES: I
really like having
a pint of Guinness, yeah.
That calms me down.
Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: Guinness
helps everything.
KELLY JONES: Guinness
is good [INAUDIBLE]..
GETHIN JONES: It's
true, it's true.
AUDIENCE: Thank you both
for the fascinating talk.
I'm sorry this is also a
little self-indulgent question,
so shut me up if you--
GETHIN JONES: No.
AUDIENCE: Around--
GETHIN JONES: All right,
enough, pass the mic off.
AUDIENCE: Around 20 years
ago, 21 years ago, me my mates
were also in a band.
We came to watch you.
And I think it was
[INAUDIBLE] Lido,
or [INAUDIBLE] or something.
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Afterwards, we were
having a few, let's say drinks,
with Stuart.
KELLY JONES: I
don't believe you.
AUDIENCE: I'm saying drinks,
because my boss is probably--
yeah, so we were in a
chat with him afterwards.
And we asked him about how
you guys got your big break
and what we could do.
And he said you used to jump
on stage while bands went off.
Like Skunk Anansie would play.
They'd go for a break.
You'd jump on to play
their instruments
and try and get your
name out that way.
Was that true, or was he
having us on the whole time?
KELLY JONES: No, when we were
playing in clubs and stuff,
we'd always go and play on other
people's equipment and stuff
like that, yeah.
And Skunk Anansie took us
on tour for a little bit.
There was a month
in 1996 where we
were opening up
for Kenickie, which
was Lauren Laverne's band.
She was really funny, actually.
Soon as we saw her on stage,
she was brilliant, [INAUDIBLE]
GETHIN JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
KELLY JONES: So we had
the Monarch's shows,
we had the Skunk Anansie shows.
We The Who, Three
Colors Red and all that.
And that was all
within three weeks.
And then you go
around the country,
and you steal their fans.
And then you go and
do your own shows.
And then there's
loads of people there.
So, no, he wasn't
completely lying.
But you never let the truth
get away with an anecdote.
GETHIN JONES: What happened
to the band, out of interest?
AUDIENCE: We were
quite successful.
GETHIN JONES: Quite successful.
Still in the garage back in--
no, I'm joking.
Anymore for Kelly?
Oh, yeah-- hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello, thanks
both for coming in.
It's such a treat to have
you come in during the week.
I had a question.
Obviously, the
music industry has
evolved since you've been
doing what you're doing.
What kind of questions
or advice do you
give to artists who are kind
of starting their careers now?
And what are the
different challenges
that you think they face to
when you were breaking through?
KELLY JONES: I don't think
I'd want to start now.
I think it's much harder for
young musicians to develop,
because I think there's
so many stats involved.
I think record companies and
management companies, and all--
not to put them in a
bad light-- but there's
a lot of statistics
people follow now more
than when we were starting out.
For example, what
they did with us was,
they wouldn't let
us play in London.
They made us avoid London.
So we'd have to play in
Newcastle, and Scotland,
and Wales, and build
a proper fan base.
And do 15 interviews a
day in every university.
So by the time the media caught
up with us, we were actually--
we had a real fan base.
So if the media kind
of turned on us,
or the record wasn't
successful, then we already
had a grounding.
So the only thing, my
advice would be really,
I think it still
stems back to the fact
the songs have to work, because
now it's a bit like the '50s.
The song is more
important than the album
really, because people are
just downloading or streaming
one song.
And if that song
is not very good,
then people are not really
going to listen to you at all.
So I think it'll always come
back to the songwriting craft
really.
GETHIN JONES: You've
been quite open,
as well, about the TV
shows now, in terms
of the manufactured bands,
with "X Factor," "The Voice,"
et cetera.
That's not really something
you ever advocated, is it?
It's not something
you're a fan of.
KELLY JONES: I don't think it's
something you can judge really.
I have been asked to
judge on all those shows.
And I'm not against the shows.
I think they're great
Saturday night tele.
Sat down with the kids when
there would be younger,
and watching, have a
laugh and all that.
But I think it's
very hard once you--
even if you win, to
go on from that point,
you're always going to be a
contestant winner or something.
I know some people have
been massively successful.
But I the majority
of those people,
it's a different way to come
into the game, then, really.
I think you have
to play in a club
where there's only three
people that know you.
You have to know what it
feels like to die on stage.
You have to feel like I
don't want to walk out
the dressing room
because I'm embarrassed
how crap I was tonight.
And unless you have
those feelings,
then you're not going to--
you can't learn by walking
into a football stadium.
You have to learn that
from the ground up.
And that's no different,
I think, from any trade.
You have to make your
mistakes yourself,
you have to walk
into your own walls.
Otherwise, you're
not really going to--
one, you're not going to
appreciate it when you get it.
And it's a bit like
a lottery winner.
You give a lottery
winner 10 million quid,
you guaranteed 99%
of them mess it up.
If you earn the
money, then somehow
you know what to do with it.
GETHIN JONES: It is
massive exposure, isn't it?
We were chatting
about the 18-year-old
on "Britain's Got
Talent" on Saturday.
And all of a sudden, bang,
she wasn't even expecting it.
Do you think you would
have coped with that at 18?
KELLY JONES: No.
I couldn't do it.
I couldn't do live
tele every Saturday.
I'd fall apart.
No chance.
GETHIN JONES: I can't do it now.
KELLY JONES: No.
I couldn't, honestly,
genuinely couldn't.
I've never enjoyed one live
TV show my entire life.
No.
I mean, when it's
finished, I like it,
but watching it back,
with the boys and a pint.
But leading up to
it, no, I'm not--
it's like [INAUDIBLE]
GETHIN JONES: So you're not
going to do "Strictly Come
Dancing" anytime soon?
KELLY JONES: I've been asked.
GETHIN JONES: Have you.
Did you watch the Welsh
guy in 2007, came third?
KELLY JONES: Was that you?
GETHIN JONES: Enjoy that?
KELLY JONES: I played
on that, though.
I have sang on that.
GETHIN JONES: I
think you have, yeah.
KELLY JONES: I've sang on that.
GETHIN JONES: Did
you vote for me?
KELLY JONES: I didn't vote, no.
Because like I just
said, I don't really
do the voting thing.
I don't like to judge, Geth.
GETHIN JONES: Got to look
after the Welsh though.
KELLY JONES: No, I
didn't, I didn't--
I didn't watch that one.
GETHIN JONES: Any
more questions?
Or we can-- oh,
yeah, OK, yeah, sure.
I should have said,
introduce yourself as well.
That would have been nice.
But it's probably a
bit too late for that.
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you guys
for coming, first of all, very
inspirational meeting.
KELLY JONES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Kelly, you mentioned
that with all the new music,
you try to experiment, bring new
things, bring new instruments.
And so one, I think
that's a common trait
that we googlers have with you.
We like experimenting.
Sometimes you quickly fail, but
sometimes you really do well.
So my question is, what
inspires you, in particular,
outside of music, that
you do, that helps
boost your creativity.
KELLY JONES: I guess I've
always took my inspiration,
from for good or for bad, from
whatever I'm going through
in my own life, on my,
if you want to call it
a journey through life.
When I started doing it,
I was like 12 years old.
When I started writing
songs I was 18.
And the 18-year-old
version of me,
compared to 44 version of me
is very different, I hope.
And there's lots of
mistakes I've made,
and lots of things I've
done, which are good and bad,
and all the rest of it.
And you have to deal with
it in different ways.
So I think it's, for
me, personally, it's
like a manifestation
of stuff that's
inside me that has to come out.
But when it comes to
song mix, and music,
and all that sort of
stuff, I take inspiration
from everything.
I listen to lots of stuff from
films, actually, sometimes.
I mean, when I was
younger, a lot of it
was conversations, a
lot of people talking,
and I would take things from
conversations, like literally
live actual conversations.
And kind of turn them into
songs and stuff like that.
And then people would come up
to me in the workman's club
when I'd go home, and start
telling me their life story
hoping I would put into a song.
But start the conversation
with, don't put this
into a song, but--
and then they
would tell me that.
So that happens a
lot, happened a lot.
GETHIN JONES: It's
true, though, isn't it?
You're not allowed to
fail anymore, especially--
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: --media.
And I suppose Google's
really good for it,
because you were
able to establish,
and so are you--
you're allowed to fail.
And if you don't fail,
how do you learn?
KELLY JONES: Yeah.
GETHIN JONES: [INAUDIBLE]
KELLY JONES: Well, I think--
no, I think you have to--
going back to when, like we
did that David Bowie tour,
we watched him do a
different show every night.
When he's in middle
America, he was
doing a very different
show, to where
he's doing when he
was on the east coast,
and like New York, and stuff.
And I learned a lot
from that, because he's
catering to different people
in different walks of life.
And you can be indulgent and
selfish, but at the same time,
you can be very smart
how you do that.
And you do have
to make mistakes.
Not every record you make
is going to be successful.
And if you don't do the
mistake, then you've
got nothing to come back
from each time either.
So it's trial and error, really.
I mean, you don't know.
And it's in so many
different people's hands
when you hand it over.
Some songs you
feel very personal.
You think people
will connect to.
They don't.
And other times, you just throw
it away, and people love it.
It's a very odd thing, really.
GETHIN JONES: Yeah.
I think that's probably--
oh, we should do one more.
Yeah, I don't know--
Craig will probably really kick
me off when we have to leave.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you so much.
I've really enjoyed
this conversation.
And I love how we've spoken a
lot about you being a family
man and about having drive.
And I just wanted to
know, being so successful,
how are you able to impart
this on your children?
Because obviously they've grown
up with seeing you succeed,
but they may not necessarily
have seen the back story.
How do you still
impart the drive?
KELLY JONES: Well,
I think anybody
that knows me, and knows
me, and knows my kids,
knows this not really based
around any kind of celebrity
status or anything like that.
We don't kind of live like that.
It's very kind of
grounded upbringing.
GETHIN JONES: They were
like totally fine with me,
weren't they?
It was really surprising.
KELLY JONES: And then,
grounding wise, I guess--
I think all of
this conversation,
like anything else,
really, I think
the most thing I've
learned in all of life
really is you have to
be honest with yourself.
And if you put the most honest
version of yourself out there,
then it becomes its own success.
Because you're being
real about stuff.
And I think with the kids, I've
always been straight with them.
I've always told them
what they want to know.
And I've always told them
what's going on, really.
And I think even today,
I told them to walk,
to come to see me, to get
the taxi, to come to here.
And then, they split up.
One called the bus.
And the whole point of the walk
was to get a bit of fresh air,
because it was a sunny day.
So we had a bit of
a moment about that.
But it was that, but then it
turns into a funny moment.
Because we have a line.
We know when they'll
apologize, and I'll
apologize if I'm wrong.
And then we'll have
a crack about it.
But I think the difference
between my generation growing
up and theirs, is that when
your parents would give you
a bollocking when you were a
kid, and then they'd walk off,
you didn't quite know why.
But now, I'll give
them a bollocking,
but then I'll
explain to them why.
And then we'll have
a chat about that.
And look, it's not perfect
by any way or means.
I've never brought up a
14-year-old girl before,
or a 12-year-old girl,
or a 3-year-old girl.
I'm learning how to do it.
So each time it happens,
I'll kick myself to death
when I go to bed, because
I've messed it up,
or I haven't done it
right or whatever.
And then my wife
will say, you're
being ridiculous and
all the rest of it.
But that's the way I am.
I over-think pretty
much everything.
GETHIN JONES: And then write it
down and make loads of money.
KELLY JONES: And then
make a song, yeah.
Write it down, make some money,
and then they take it all.
It's a funny circle, really.
GETHIN JONES: Full circle.
Which is probably the perfect
way to finish things off,
I think.
I think so.
Listen, Kelly,
thank you so much.
KELLY JONES: Cheers, mate.
GETHIN JONES: Thank
you very much.
Ladies and gents, Kelly Jones.
[APPLAUSE]